*dramatic cue* i can now manipulate my audience
*gasps* omg pewds
I can now make videos without any substance
I can now make the same videos over and over
and still stay relevant somehow
-I ( me pewdiepie
edgar: pls stop pewds
have dyed my hair Audience: omg!!
Audience: I CANT BELIEVE THIS YES!1!
little  teenage girls will bow before me ( bows)
they will buy all my merchandise
they will click like on all my videos
Some say i am the new Tana Mongeau ( omg pews got fucked by a toothbrush)
of the internet
Okay let's just–let's just take out all
the comparisons so you can just fu–
shu–shut up and move on
Jack Frost, Danny Phantom, Dante from Dante's Inferno
albino Kazoo Kid ( SEXAY)
people are already in outrage
why sad face , sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face
sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, ( A lot of sad faces amirite)  sad face
sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face, sad face
WHYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYYY
your hair is awful!
BLUEGHH
(Womitin-pfft hehe
hehuhuhu
stop change it BACK
what made you think that ''dyeing'' your hair white
was a good idea have you heard of
vIEWS  i can literally make a 10-minute
video with no substance about my hair a
thing that literally anyone else on the
fucking planet will not care about Pewdie
pie white hair has the internet shook(peweminist)
but why did he do it
why did he do It?!
*feel depressed yet
there are some seriously unanswered
questions AR EN I mean it's
practically been covered by every news
media outlet in the world now speaking
of PewDiePie tweeted today saying just
that I look really cute in this picture
i will probably delete later showing
here that now he dyed his hair white and
he's putting makeup on so i guess pewdiepie has
a whole new look now that * laughter of shame*  fuck did you
say scarce    so i guess pewdiepe has a new look now
now are you trying to make fun of my
hair scarce * spits ACTUALLY R.I.P*  you piece of fucking shit
you're mocking me for my physical
appearance SO I GUESS POOPEEPIE HAS A NEW LOOK-
how could you do that
I AM  disappointed in you Scarce
I thought you were better than that
#R.I.P
let's see what you guys thought about my
haircut because your opinions matter
more to me than anyone elses is my
chemical romance back together now? I
mean- R.I.PPP
getting throwback feels from your
hair man
god dammit forgot about Gerard I'm a
little scared how fuckable i am with
makeup
smash or pass make your pick is he HUAHAHHAH*oink*AHAA*oink*HAHAHA!
turning into a massive faggot listen I
will do anything anything to get out of
this YouTube hellhole
hey goods you have to drink the bleach
not put it in your hair
now I'm all paranoid my hair and shit STAHP
oh shit i forgot
hey hows it going bros my name is POOOOOODIEPEPIEEEEEE- and
welcome to FRAIDAIS WITH POOPIEPAAAA
I wanna--  actually--you know
all jokes aside I wanted to make an update
video today it's been awhile i know i've
been bitching and complaining a lot
lately and i want to say i am sorry i
wanted this video to be positive so
let's talk about some positive things  *R.I.P*
I can't oh I gotta go ya i got an update
on the whole moderator things i said i
would add you guys as moderators
well turns out i can't i tried three
times now I add people as moderators
whenever i refresh the page
they're all gone that's really good
that feature is there.. thats not really positive is it *chuckles*
oh of course I know
hey tuber happy valentines day update
it's actually really cool i know a lot
of Arrgghh no one plays the game
anymore yeah really really funny ( i play et ;-;)
there's a lot of people playing the game
myself included and in fact anyone who
is cool like me is playing the game look
how I'm playing right now
*waiting music)
this event is only laughing 12 days so
if you want to get like the unique items
you can only get it during these days if
you have the game installed check it out
and download I there's also new feature
called networks where you basically can
join each other's network it's pretty
cool you can join my network called
"plzkillme"
honestly I have blown away by the
creativity of people playing the game
because the net-- the online feature is
working really well now and I think when
it's the game with knew there was too
many people playing it and it just didn't
work properly but seeing how well people
implement the theme it's just it's so
cool to see people being creative in so
this this thing with PewDiePie this is
the winner so cool
this is a second this is the third oh
yeah I rank 232 in my own fucking game
about myself
Bravo me good job Felix a lot of you
guys have also been asking about slippy
if he alive haha..-I dont fu-i wouldn't just kill  slippy
okay like I'm not a fucking
psychopath
there we go I'm nervous oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh wait
anyway i'll show you like he's fine
say something quickly tell them you're
fine don't shit on me right now you look
like draco malfoy we caught aids but you
do not have to comment about my hair
it's a compliment okay fine you want to
go back don't you how about you give me a kiss first
no pls
th-thank you see he didn't even take
shit
no shit i forgot about the most
important thing we're in the office uhhhhh we
are in the old penguin
club Penguin office and last video i did you
guys basically crashed the servers of
the game so I'm proud of you basically
our job was to to stop penguin from
dying and we crashed server
but that's pretty good i love this new
office it's coming together really
nicely downstairs were literally
shooting a show called scare PewDiePie
game over
not sure if I'm allowed to say that but
it's really cool
they were they literally built a set in
like just a few days and we can use that
afterwards so I'm so proud I'm so i- i
really love doing bigger shows and stuff
like that the problem is I don't have
time for it it always involves me like
going to LA or something like that and
the fact that i can literally just go
downstairs to shoot a show it's so
fucking cool to me i am so thrilled
about this office and I'd really really
really don't want to get thrown out we
had someone like a dream come true to
just have everything here I'd love
this place more youtubers coming in
Peters been using it a lot marzias has been
using it and it's just got a good vibe
it i really enjoy it so there's a lot of
stuff going on here is the set
MOOORKAPLLIEEEEEER
cinnamon toast can everyone ioEHHHGG BLUU
just kidding its edgar
my god I broke it
I don't know if anyone asked that was
not me
ok so stepping up the game in 2017 the
half
this is not a blogging camera fucking
awkward hellhole we have this chalk
Taylor has everyone been drawing all
kinds of shit on pjs especially in
different especially appreciate it
because Donald Trump i know a lot of
people are going to look at this would
be like all pretty pie has an office now
he's treating YouTube as a job i always
used to think that it was I had so much
advantage because like I could just
record at home and I can just do
everything at home but I find that it's
so much better to separate your home and
my job I guess youtube is my job there
you go everyone I waste less time
I go somewhere to record my video and
when i'm home i can just relax and turn
everything off which is really hard as a
youtuber so protip if you're youtuber and
you can afford gettingan office get
an office anyway let's go back
Jesus christ Ainsley is fucking terrifying
oh my god
so that's you know actually something
positive hey I did it didn't even have
to force it out okay well I need to
force out some some positivity as well
so it feels really good to just sit down
and not having to get ready and talk to
you guys just want to apologize for the
way I looking the way I found you guys
are my best friend i always want to keep
it real with you guys but honestly it
feels really really good just to not have to get all ready
and like sit down and talk to you
uhhhhh no for real
thank you for all the support as always
I feel like people are finally getting
over these fucking  comments with like
how we at week I wish he just play a
game and and all these fucking like a
prefer poop I in 1984 I think people
making these jokes instead and that it's
really nice that people are finally
getting over and I can just kind of do
what i want and people appreciating me
doing what I want as well I know I focus
a lot of negative that doesn't mean i
don't see the positive and I apologize
if I'm always after like the dumb shit
people saying only giving them attention
because there's a lot of you that are
generally nice people and you deserve
some love too so hey if you ever left me
a nice comment i want you right now to
take your hand and place it places
behind your back and pat yourself give
yourself a pat and imagine that it's my
hand don't do don't get all weird and
sexual it's just it's just a nice little
gesture so that we can do this together
thanks ok that's enough thank you
that being said that's all i have to say